very happy to Welcome to the podcast
Monica Guzman the author of I never
thought of it that way how to have
fearlessly curious conversations and
dangerously divided times and the chief
Storyteller for one of my favorite
organizations in all the world braver
Angels welcome Monica how are you hey
hey I am doing great it's good to be
here so yeah how did you become so
passionate about trying to have curious
conversation I mean you're a naturally
curious person that seems to be a
driving theme in your career
um uh but the your book what I love
about it is that it actually is
practical
um it's born of the you know the
experience you've had getting hundreds
maybe thousands of people to open up
yeah that was definitely a goal from the
beginning uh I had read a lot about why
we're here how we got here it's a really
interesting problem and we haven't
solved it the first part of my book is
called SOS it's the call for help
sorting othering siloing those are the
three forces that brought us here yeah I
mean it's a real you know but the other
four-fifths of the book uh walk people
through this path where first we
understand curiosity and how it works in
our brains when we when we pay attention
to the gap between what we know and what
we don't know it's this incredible
craving that can get us to do so much
and so you can actually turn it on you
don't have to wait for it to come up you
can turn it on and channel it and Target
right the things you don't understand
and then we learn the power of
conversation especially a one-to-one
conversation it's people are you know
scared of them in some ways because they
are so unpredictable and so powerful
that it doesn't even matter almost who
you are outside the conversation in that
conversation you can have this
extraordinary ability to cut through any
divide if you if you know how to ask
perceptive and Powerful questions if you
know how to stay respectful and build
traction with each other and then you
know the book goes on through a series
of solutions or you know things to try
that are based um around a couple of
core ideas and I'll mention one of them
now which is that knowing where people
are coming from is one of the best ways
to understand where they are so asking
questions about people's experiences
that led to their views and asking
questions about the concerns people have
around their issues are great ways to
not be so judgmental so that you can be
curious when you're curious you actually
cannot be judgmental these are two
different modes
um so pushing us away from judgment back
into curiosity back into curiosity back
into curiosity does amazing things for
our relationships people you know I've
learned as a journalist people love to
talk about themselves oh yeah if it's in
a generous context they want to tell
their story who doesn't want to be heard
yeah most of us love to hear ourselves
talk because we're we're very wise we
have a lot I think we think we are but
you know what but no the serious point
is you know we live in a society that
that sort of still thinks well you know
you're only as wise as your education
you're only as wise as your intelligence
you know you're only as wise as these
things and we don't we don't think about
wisdom all that much we all have life we
all are experts in life and we have
walked our own paths through it and
everybody's path is interesting no
matter what you conclude if you believe
a bunch of baloney your path still
contains a lot of Truth
and since so it's those things that we
need to mind and and look behind you
know all those places that we feel we're
stuck look behind that to the person's
path to their story and you'll you'll
discover pretty interesting stuff
that'll help you relate and connect not
agree that's not that's not the point
but relate and connect so that we can
do stuff together
yeah Live Together live together so we
we can't let this conversation end
without talking about family a bit do
you have a family of your own now yes
two kids nine and seven wow me too uh
same ages nine and six two boys so your
parents must now be very happy that uh
their their grandparents and all that
jazz um so they have no choice but uh oh
they love it they love it but you you
talked about how you've had political
disagreements uh with them for for a
long time uh go ahead and give guidance
to folks who might have a somewhere
situation uh in their family where they
feel like there's this uh political
divide yeah and this is where you know
my my inbox has become like a a
confession Booth you know a place where
a lot of people are telling me about
these stories with family where there's
such strong relationships one story I
can think of that I shared with braver
angels is a woman named Courtney who's
very purple herself doesn't consider
herself Reddit blue but cares deeply
about some political issues and loves
her father dearly and and there was a
moment where they fought so hard about
politics that her father said that's it
we just can't talk about politics
anymore no no and so I mean that seemed
like okay for maybe a bit but what
Courtney realized and I think a lot of
people are realized is that when when
you care deeply about certain issues and
and you know you're very concerned about
them
um then it feels like when you can't
talk about politics
you can't even be yourself and the
people you love can't know you or see
you and and that's the thing that we
can't
that's no way to live in a way right
like if we have these meaningful
relationships what gives them meaning is
that we can be our full selves around
each other so that's the conundrum for a
lot of people the solution is well we
just don't talk about politics and maybe
that's fine you know if it's just
Thanksgiving dinners and here and there
and you keep that bridge open that's
fine but in times like this when it's
just so much more heat and stress you
want to be able to do something about it
so among the the most powerful I think
things that you can try is we tend to
want to engage with each other on the
level of logic and syllogism and reason
right why do you believe what you
believe how could you possibly believe
what you believe you know but even if
you take the the disrespectful tone out
and you leave why do you believe what
you believe even then we think of why as
such a powerfully curious question but
in times of division and suspicion why
puts people on the defensive it makes
them Reach for uh what's the talking
point what's the thing that oh gosh I
better show up well to this relative of
mine or they're going to think less of
me or here we go I'm being put to the
test it's like you're on trial we're
putting each other on trial when we ask
why and everyone has to think of their
reason and and they won't think of
candid reasons usually you know they'll
just go for what feels safe because so
many people are not even comfortable
sharing their political beliefs so
instead ask questions around how
how did you come to believe what you
believe
you know what comes up for you like so
Dad I know that you and I disagree
hugely about immigration and I'm I'm
really curious like what what kind of
things have happened you know in your
life that that make you make you think
that your position on this is is really
important and ask it that way and and
what happens is that the questions
naturally carry a lot less judgment and
what you're doing is you're collecting
sort of knowledge about that person's
path that person's experience how did
you come to this mistake in an opinion
I'm kidding right well that's the thing
you got to peel off the disrespect keep
them curious people think that every
question is curious like journalists
know better right some questions are
just accusations disguised as questions
they're just gotcha they're meant to
disqualify people
I I know that you have
you know and sometimes it's in the
public good because it's a powerful
person blah blah blah we know that but
with each other on a one-to-one
relationship level if we're trying to
build trust you know if we're trying to
build trust then we have to accept we
have to accept each other first which is
the radical a thing and then understand
each other and then judge I mean what
we're doing is we're judging recklessly
because we don't even see we're not even
seeing each other clearly
so when we judge what are we judging
we're judging projections we're judging
ghosts
you know that's no way to build a
society so we have to fix that we have
to get each other's stories and have
them and invite people to take us on a
tour through their path and the concerns
and the experiences that make it up uh
instead of put them on trial wow you
could really do a lot of good Monica
can I can I tell you there's there's a
woman who left a review of my book on
him it like brought me to tears but she
said that she had not talked to her 85
year old mother who had voted for Trump
for years and that she read the book and
she thought the tips were pretty good
and so she put them to work and she says
you know she started listening to her
mom and asking different kinds of
questions and now she says their
relationship is really good and I I mean
that made it all worth it you know yeah
that would make everything worth it that
made it all worth it I will share with
you that uh I got dozens of times over
my campaign
um like thank you you helped bring our
family together because you know like
you helped uh us feel like we could like
agree on something yeah and like that
was like an incredible blessing to hear
I was like wow yeah you know another
thing that someone said to me too is
like they had a um Trump supporting mom
um and they themselves were blue and
then their mom said to them that like
Yang is the only Democrat credit I would
support because he doesn't feel like
he's judging us at all and I was like
holy cow like this is probably very
important lesson there yeah and I mean
she's right like I have zero judgment on
um people based upon their political
beliefs I actually thinking I understand
what's driving a lot of what what's
happening in in this country yeah you
made such an important contribution and
you're doing it every day
um I I but I'm going to wrap on this
thought that's been stuck in my head a
little bit I'm going to run it by you
and see see what you think so it feels
like the Republican Party under Trump
has become this version of sort of angry
toxic masculinity like the crazy uncle
or or Grandpa and then the Democratic
party has become this
um somewhat like uh you know identity
Laden uh moralism that like most people
don't feel is genuine and and so when
you talk about like the fan the country
needing family of therapy like this is
an idea that's stuck with me yeah I mean
I think I think both parties these are
in this place of confusion and and panic
and a little bit of Madness because we
all are
uh and that that's what happens I think
when everything's a fun house mirror and
we're not sure what to do about it so
yeah the parties are just an extension
the same way that media is an extension
and politics politicians right their
behavior in the conventions all an
extension of of what we're feeling on
the ground and what's going on on the
ground every time I talk with my parents
so they're they're conservative they
voted for Trump twice
um and I'm liberal but as I say in the
book I I've gotten to the point where if
I know that if I were them
I would have voted for Trump too
wow that's a very very big and knowing
that yeah like it was a tough thing to
admit and it took a bit to be able to
admit it in the book but getting to the
place where I could admit that it was it
was sort of well here they are and here
I am now what
it's it's not I need to defeat you I
need to change you yes a different
question it's we need to build a society
together that somehow balances uh the
different stacks of values that we have
people think people look across the
divide and say they don't share my
values but but actually they do they
just stack them in a different order for
different issues you know when we
develop different communities different
communities develop different languages
and over time if they don't interact
that well it's a Tower of Babel you know
and that's what's happening too so
that's only adding to the panic and the
frustration and the madness so we need
some of these uh you know it counter
things but again I've I've talked to
members of Congress you know one-on-one
on background people want to fix this
and and I for one am really encouraged
by the work a lot of politicians are
doing um including yourself just anyone
who's really tackling this Beast instead
of just accepting the game as it is we
need that
foreign
[Music]